be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
so as we continue our discussion on our
comic book concept series and how to
kill the x-men we pick up now with
Quicksilver Wolverine Archangel Jubilee
forge chamber Phoenix and Polaris now
for those of you guys who have not seen
my last video on this which you'll find
in the description at the conclusion of
the onslaught soccer which focus on the
minds of Xavier and Magneto coming
together in forming a psychic entity
because onslaught had laid waste to the
Marvel Universe Charles Xavier had
outlined a set of protocols designed to
hinder or kill members of the x-men
should they go awry and use their powers
in a bid for world domination so
focusing on Quicksilver because his
powers combined with modifications from
the High Evolutionary allow him to run
at speeds of up to 76 hundred miles per
hour since the effects of friction and
wind resistance play no part in his
movements while running he presents
himself as a difficult foe to oppose
this combined with the fact that a
SuperSpeed extended to his mind as well
meant that in addition to extremely fast
movement he's also capable of analyzing
situations at extremely fast speeds
sometimes even countering the actions of
his foes before they're aware that he's
present that said despite these
abilities Quicksilver has no protection
against conventional weapons aside from
his speed meaning that his skin can be
pierced in the same capacity as a normal
human
Barnes someone shooting him with a
sniper from a hundred yards away the
best means of taking down Quicksilver
comes in a wide angled attack which can
blanket a larger area with energy
meaning the Cyclops is best suited due
to his optic blast being capable of
achieving this feat while also emitting
enough energy to completely eradicate
Quicksilver and transitioning to
Archangel on the surface his powers
seemed lackluster in comparison to the
rest of the x-men's line-up possessing
physical wings that allow him to fly
because these wings were augmented using
the celestial technology of apocalypse
his original powers of flight were
enhanced owing to the metallic structure
of his wings making him more aerodynamic
this combined with the fact that his
training as part of the x-men allowed
him to protect his mind against psychic
attacks and control maneuverability to
the point that his agility rivaled Beast
means that not only can he fly he's also
extremely difficult to manipulate
psychically
and is very difficult to catch as a
result the metallic projectile shot from
his wings can easily pierce the target
exposing him to the project house dose
of neurotoxin rendering a target
paralyzed temporarily
the downside to this is that Archangels
wings also respond to his subconscious
mind indicating that he does not have
complete and total control to this end
the best person capable of defeating
Archangel is actually a couple people
using her powers of telekinesis Jean
Grey could render him mo with Wolverine
severing his wings from his body
following this Archangel would be a
normal man capable of being killed with
any conventional weapon moving to
Jubilee as she presents a credible
threat despite her abilities prior to
losing her powers after the house of M
possessing the power to emit plasmids
that range from blinding flashes of
light to concussive blasts capable of
destroying physical objects Jubilee also
possessed a natural immunity to
telepathy making her impervious to the
effects of telepaths regardless of their
level as a result and through her
training as both a member of the x-men
and student of Emma Frost under
Generation X her control over the power
she possessed were incredible allowing
her to force the plasmids into the mind
of a human or mutant simulating a stroke
with this in mind the best person suited
to defeat your belief comes in the form
of Bishop because he's capable of
absorbing the powers of other mutants
and channeling him back with his power
being passive Bishop does not have to
concentrate instead his body will
automatically absorb Jubilees powers
whenever they're used allowing Bishop to
engage in hand-to-hand combat easily
overpower a Jubilee due to his superior
strength and training now moving on a
forge because he has the power to
intuitively know how objects function
and retain his knowledge without
degradation the powers of forge should
play no part in a foes desire to destroy
him instead emphasis should be placed on
his physical body with forge possessing
a mechanical leg and a mechanical arm
the metallic nature of these constructs
proves to be his weakness and that
because polaris possess all the same
powers as her father magneto she could
simply rip forges mechanical limbs off
leaving him with only one arm and one
leg making him easy prey now picking up
with chamber as one of Marvel's most
powerful x-men he presents an extremely
difficult situation because his physical
body does not actually contain organs
and instead houses energy equivalent to
a nuclear bomb if his physical body were
destroyed he would continue to live on
jumping from one host body to the next
this combined with telepathic immunity
as well as telekinesis being useless
against pure energy means the regular
roster of x-men would find themselves
incapable of going too
to toe against chamber to this end while
chamber cannot technically be killed the
best means of defeating him comes
through cannonball while Sam Guthrie's
most prominent use of his powers takes
place through projecting himself in a
forward direction
much like negasonic teenage warhead from
the Deadpool movie the thermochemical
energy he emits is not limited to
projectile flight instead he's also
capable of admitting his power in such a
way that he can encase and imprison
others meeting Sam could destroy the
physical body of chamber after which he
could encase chambers energy form until
such a time that the x-man can make a
decision on what to do
transitioning to Polaris as the presumed
daughter of magneto her powers mirror
her father's but to a lesser degree
however the length at which she can
manipulate the electromagnetic spectrum
remains the same and that she's capable
of controlling metallic objects
generating emps create electromagnetic
force fields capable of blocking most
forms of energy based attacks as well as
allow herself to fly however despite her
time with the x-men and x-factor Polaris
does not have training and psychic
attacks allowing her mind to easily be
accessed by someone of sufficient power
as a result the best person suited to
defeat and kill culeros comes in the
form of Jean Grey whose telepathic and
telekinetic powers are largely
considered to be the most powerful and
Marvel Comics to this end Jean Grey
could easily dominate the mind of
Polaris shutting down her ability to
access her powers or else placing her in
a comatose state allowing pilars to be
killed by any number of conventional
means now moving on to Jean Grey herself
despite having omega-level telepathy and
telekinesis Jean must still focus these
powers on a target to actually achieve a
desired effect in addition to this
despite her training as part of the
x-men emphasis was placed on her
telepathy and telekinesis meaning she
has no real skills in terms of
hand-to-hand combat as a result the best
person capable of defeating Jean comes
in the form of Quicksilver using a
SuperSpeed to analyze a situation as
well as engaged Jean Quicksilver could
move faster than Jean can predict
meaning that by the time she was able to
focus her telepathy and telekinesis on
Quicksilver he would likely have already
engaged in a barrage of attacks
rendering her completely unconscious
that said if we were to assume that Jean
possessed the Phoenix force at a time
that everybody just kind of basically
screwed finally and picking up with
wolverine this bit requires us to ignore
the death of Wolverines storyline where
he was in case and adamantium assuming
that we focus on the nature of his
healing powers Wolverine is immune to
virtually all forms of injury even with
the Days of Future past when his
physical body was destroyed
Wolverine returned a life due to his
adamantium skeleton keeping his brain
physically protected allowing for his
healing factor to remain impact as a
result Wolverines death would have to
occur in a couple of stages the first
would come through the use of a
carbonadium sword a material resulting
from russia's attempt to recreate true
adamantium as well as someone skilled in
martial arts to this end Wolverine could
actually be killed by a non mutant in
the form of Deadpool because waves
actions in killing Wolverine were so
highly popularized in the Deadpool kills
the Marvel Universe story with
carbonadium neutralizing Wolverines
healing factor Deadpool could then
several Wolverines head from his body
using an adamantium sword because of
this and since Wolverine cannot
regenerate a full body his death would
be guaranteed so long as both a head and
the body remain separated from each
other with that being said as far as I'm
aware unless somebody knows other
information out there that I may not
have this is the totality of the Xavier
protocols there's no more protocols on
this so I'm kind of curious if you guys
have questions or if you guys are
curious to see a discussion on like a
versus Series characters fighting each
other or if you were interested in
seeing how superheroes would be killed
even though they're not part of the
Xavier protocols post them down in the
comment section I'm curious to see what
you guys come up with and I will catch
you all later peace